welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is rollin adorno rubin post Haluk
professor of Spanish and chair of the
department of Spanish and Portuguese at
yale university professor adorno has
done groundbreaking work in latin
american literary studies and has won
several awards for it her scholarly work
focuses on the field of literary
cultural production in colonial latin
america she became most well known for
her 1986 book waman puma writing and
resistance in colonial Peru which
centered on the analysis of the
pictorial and prose text than a native
and Ian wrote to the king of Spain her
book offered a vivid look at the
confrontation of a writer from an
indigenous American culture with its
colonial conquerors and revealed the
survival of a vital native legacy more
recently she has explored the Spanish
writings about the new world that
includes both a prize-winning
three-volume book on early Spanish
exploration of the area now part of the
u.s. Southwest and one which we will
discuss here that takes up the role that
the historical theoretical and polemic
works written during the colonial period
in Latin America have played in the
history of Latin American literature and
thought in November she was appointed to
the National Council on the humanities
welcome professor adorno Thank You
Marilyn it's a pleasure to be here
congratulations on your National Council
on the humanities appointment tell us
about the council and what your role
will be the National Council on the
humanities is a 26 member board it is
appointed by the President of the United
States with confirmation by the US
Senate and this 26 member board serves
as an advisor or an advisory board to
the chairman of the National Endowment
for the Humanities in addition we review
grant applications or do a final review
of all grant application
asians that are presented to the neh I
was nominated by President Obama on July
seventh rather July 9th of this year
2009 and my confirmation by the US
Senate was on November fifth wonderful
so let's talk about your academic work
you've written several books on colonial
latin american literature and now you
are at work on the origins of the study
of the spanish world in the u.s. in the
19th century what drew you to research
them this project really comes out of my
background in a way I was raised on a
farm in Iowa and I went to a one-room
country schoolhouse and there we learned
as small children that christopher
columbus sailed the ocean blue many
years later I began to wonder how it was
that Christopher Columbus became part of
the prehistory of the United States and
so that has led me to this study of 19th
century North American literature the
beginnings of our own national
literature in this country and carrying
it through the 19th century there are
many landmarks along the way but I
always like to point to Thomas Jefferson
who was the first to recommend the
teaching of the modern languages in the
u.s. University both at the College of
William and Mary and at the University
of Virginia which he founded it was his
view that the greater part of our early
history is written in Spanish and took a
very hemispheric approach to the study
of the Spanish world the Spanish new
world and thus it began to be a part of
our own legacy it was really the time of
the foundation of our national
literature that Spain's new world became
prominent for us your recently published
book the polemics of possession in
Spanish American narrative when the
Modern Language Association of America's
Katherine singer Cove X PRIZE give us an
overview of the book and what you argue
in it well the heart of the book is
really the argument that the debates
that were held in the 16th century
shortly after the
Spanish arrived to the Americas debates
on the right of Spanish Dominion to
those territories debates on the
treatment of the native populations
these debates stood at the core of 16th
century Spanish thought on their being
in the New World my argument is that on
the basis of that we find those debates
shall I say reiterated new positions
taken in the early historical writings
about Spanish America and in the
writings that continued and some of
those topics we see rehearse to this day
in contemporary Latin American
literature so the argument is that the
core of the Latin American literary
tradition for Spain really rests on
these early debates on the right to
foreign domination and the treatment of
the native peoples in those lands a
topic that we find persists today and
other domains of course okay and in the
book what are some of the conclusions
you reach well the conclusions the basic
conclusions that I've reached is that
there are some issues that are pertinent
all throughout history and of course if
we think of Latin America before it was
called Latin America which begins in the
19th century from the time of Columbus
onward the persistence of these issues
in one forum or another has never never
subsided so it is one of the enduring
legacies actually of Latin American
literature and culture and thought
that's really the major conclusion okay
and how did you do your research for the
book I imagine you're fluent in Spanish
yes of course and I also write in
spanish okay but for this book naturally
the source materials are always Spanish
text Spanish documents spanish-language
documents from that period and I began
like I suppose any literary studies
person begins nowadays which was by
reading the texts very closely there is
a marvelous book that was published in
the 1920s it was actually
edited by a venerated principle of Hill
House high school here in New Haven it
was part of a series and in that series
he edited the works of Washington Irving
the Washington Irving biography of
Christopher Columbus but the series
title very interestingly was the series
shall I say subtitle was the best way to
know what an author is has written is to
read what he and now we would add or she
has actually stated so it always starts
with the text and generating the
research questions out of what is before
me in those writings so it's very much a
work of libraries and archives ok and
does it take you around the world
actually it takes me on the short
circuit from Washington DC in the ubs
Library of Congress up to Harvard and
the Widener and Houghton libraries
that's because so much early Americana
if we might call it that the great works
that were written mostly in Spanish but
later also in english and french and
dutch of course on the new world became
the object of us collectors in the late
eighteenth and early nineteenth
centuries so a great many of these
precious imprints are now located in
research libraries here it's not to say
that they're not in Spain and the
republics of Latin America but it is
that some of those copies have come to
this country so most of my research is
actually done in libraries in the US on
very old Spanish materials okay let's go
back to an earlier book you have written
about waman Puma yes what drew you to
him and what did you find such very
interesting that you would that would
cause you to write the book I never
imagined as many people did not that
Indians wrote books i discovered this
book it had been published but its
manuscript exists in Copenhagen in the
Royal Library of Denmark as a matter of
fact I read this book this manuscript
shall i say decades ago and i was struck
by the fact that here was somebody who
was not for
spanish language tradition his native
language was Quechua who learned reading
and writing probably as an adolescent in
the service of the missionary clergy
from Spain and read books and took it
upon himself to write one in fact this
to me was a revelation and there are
some other examples of it both from
early colonial Mexico as well as this
one from early colonial Peru and other
places to show that one of the means of
retaining cultural vitality in those
early times was to learn the language of
the European Conqueror and in fact write
the early history of one's own country
in that language destined both for a
native but also for Spanish in this case
the Spanish king of Spain a Spanish
audience as well so I answered the
research question there I guess you
might say what did Indians read in the
early colonial period and the other part
of it is the dynamic of not being able
to be a complete revolutionary a
complete radical in those days because
under that is for a person under
colonialism it meant dealing with the
powers that be and in their language and
these processes of cultural
accommodation at the same time as it
includes cultural resistance and their
complexities we're a very very
interesting topic to me okay and final
question what was some of the most
surprising things you found in doing
your research overall I'd say the thing
that always surprises me is that any
assumptions that I may begin with have
to be checked and usually corrected yeah
I'm always surprised how little we
understand times long gone but I'm also
convinced that we need to bring them to
the present with us even though our
interest is generated by present-day
concerns it's one way of looking back
however imperfectly through that Looking
Glass wow thank you so much for being
here today
sharing some of your work thank you so
much Marilyn it's been a great pleasure
for more information about professor
adorno enter work please visit our
website at yale edu backslash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you